always
can't be cool don't have it in me
so
it's time for drew's news your daily
basket of good news eggs very fresh and
with me at the desk is a good egg indeed
it's frosty ross matthew
hi everybody that's some sort of yolk
all right well first up we've got some
great tv plans for you this weekend
tomorrow on hbo max you can watch the
36th annual rock and roll hall of fame
induction ceremony
i have to tell you this awards show
literally had me so star struck
it was unlike other award shows if
there's just something about it i can't
wait to see it on hbo because being
there in person
it was
it was really unique and different what
did you see there who was there i saw
jay-z i hung out with him yes
i saw my friend pat smear who i've known
for almost 30 years he's the guitarist
and the foo fighters they were inducted
i saw her walking by me i almost fell
over
at j.lo there's always room for j.lo
right literally it was a carol king and
taylor swift i never got a glimpse of
them like it was just too many people
for one night wow it was so special epic
performances and i was lucky enough to
be there
to honor
the introducing of my favorite band in
the world that informed who i would
become when i was a child the go-go's
wow
yeah
i changed my life so i
i was so honored to do this well you
didn't just do it it wasn't some sort of
formal introduction you paid tribute to
their debut album beauty and the beat
the first record you ever got as a kid
right yeah it changed my life forever
because it was girls that were girls you
know a lot of what we tried to do with
charlie's angels was so informed by the
go-go's for me which was when girls want
to do what boys do you don't have to be
and act like a man in order to do it be
a girl but be capable yes true
well
and i love i love that when you
introduce them you really went for it
and actually we have a clip oh really
yeah take a look at this
i always thought the go-go's
was such a perfect name
for that band
so full of kinetic energy
it fits their music and their spirit and
mind too
and you know what
you always have to just go for it
now my childhood fantasy is fulfilled
but it isn't about me
this is as true blue of a love letter
from their biggest fan
from the first band i ever loved
here's a look at the go-gos
non-musician
inducting so i also really you know
just wanted to honor the go-go's as they
deserve to be honored well from the rock
and roll hall of fame now we have a
member of the ross matthews hall of fame
i'm talking about betty white oh
come
the on who doesn't want to be betty
white if you don't like betty white i
don't like you all right
the comedy legend she's got another big
birthday coming up on january 17th she's
going to turn 100 years old
wow
what a life what a legend what a life
what a woman holy cow i know and still
just better and better and better and to
celebrate cnn reports one company is
offering to pay you to watch betty
white's best work anyone want that job
choice mutual insurance is going to pay
one lucky betty white fan a thousand
dollars to watch 10 hours of her film
and tv work and you can apply yeah you
can apply on their site right now
just send some love betty
we love you i got to work with betty
white a bunch on the tonight show you
remember i was on the tonight show with
jay leno back in the day yes we do right
that's where we all met you yeah
well she would come on there and we'd do
things and they'd be like okay ross
you're going to be in the sketch with
betty white i'd be like are we sure this
is a good idea like me and what was she
like she was like the nicest person you
know it was like you felt like you were
just talking to like the sweet lady down
the street except it was betty white you
know
and i'll never forget how kind she was
thank you for that fly on the wall
experience ross welcome
that's exciting it was exciting i know
well i'm very passionate about this next
story
um
netflix is moving on up to the big
screen
timeout reports that the streaming
service has purchased the bay theater in
pacific palisades it's a legendary
theater that closed over the pandemic
but netflix is opening at backup to
feature films in the netflix library
like their new western the harder they
fall and adam mckay's don't look up but
what i want to know is
and this is important what are they
going to charge for popcorn oh this is
this gets you going i just went to the
movie theater with my daughters
and their two friends because they were
having a sleepover okay so it's four
four kids four kids and two adults two
adults we bought stuff at the concession
stand it was 170 dollars
and i sat there with my jaw on the floor
and i just thought
i feel very privileged to have the means
to say i can afford this right now
and i have every bone in my body saying
this is unacceptable
but they charge that at the concession
stands because they have to pay their
rent they're not doing it to us they're
trying to stay open themselves and i
understand that and i empathize i just
want to find out a way that we don't
have to charge people those kinds of
prices to take their families to the
theater we got to make it affordable and
fill those theaters up
because netflix
changed the world so maybe they can
change the theater going experience too
of course they can ted sarandos i love
you by the way head of netflix old
friend and shout out to you can't wait
to see what you do with this new
endeavor well before we go we've got the
perfect mini treat that's just fun to
eat it's time for food news
okay
all right
in this world you know there are two
types of people sorry two types of
people there are pie people and cake
people i am a pie person uh and if you
are too buckle up because we're gonna
rock your little pie world pop sugar
reports just in time for thanksgiving
you can now get the dash mini pie maker
it's only 15 bucks you can get this
little pie press to make delicious pies
at home look we got it right here look
this is how it works see it's a little
thing like this like almost like a
waffle maker but for a pie i eat right
out of yeah
we have an apple pie here and a pumpkin
pie
fifteen dollars
i love this
thank you dash get out of my car and
into my dreams
[Music]